There we go. Welcome to another Zoom call. It's a reminder to make sure you're checking your announcements.
Last week, we went into detail to write software update. Actually, they pulled the 6.4 right now
because they're having issues with it. But still watch this video. It's on your member site.
Again, if your 6.0 current software is working defined, there's no need for you to update.
Right now, we can't even update to 6.4 because they are fixated.
So just keep running your programs. If you did update to 6.4, make sure you look
at the information on the member site. I will go over that one again. So I went over that detail
last week and it's all on the member site. Okay, so first question. A friend watched a video where you
talked about a smoothie with carrots, celery, and apple in it. Do you have a recipe or a suggested
ingredients for that smoothie? No, I don't. So we have a lot of people that will be juicing.
And typically, this is probably the most common juicing protocol for cancer. This was really
big part of Max Gerson's juicing protocol for cancer, which is carrot, celery, and apple.
And then making a smoothie out of it. Personally, I don't like smoothies. I like to drink
my drink. Do not have to be thicker or you have to cut it to a doubt. So I like to leave things
juiced. So there's times that I'm juiced carrots, apples, and celery, sometimes put other things
in it, whatever vegetables that I had in it, whatever you have. So we have people that are juicing
all sorts of different things. And then if you, it depends on how you define a smoothie, then some
people are putting, it's a protein powder in it, then some people are putting their greens in it.
They're, they're a pedestal. There are other things that the powders that they're on, they're adding
to that. I guess you're calling that a smoothie. So I've called that a smoothie. That's my wife calls
it a smoothie. She puts some yogurt in it and different things like that. So it's just how you
want to make it. If you are just blending and not juicing, I do believe if you have a really
strong blender, like a Vitamix, or even a very good new triple end of some kind, you can, you know,
blend the carrots, apple, and celery. I think you would have hard time with some of the, at least,
I think the carrots and celery would be difficult for a blender to get through. But I do think with
the Vitamix, you could blend it up and make a smoothie out of it. Really, when we talk about
smoothie, you're just adding other things to a juice. Do you have any other greens, powders,
suggestions that don't have stevia? Well, so, yes, there are some other greens, powders that we
have on the store that don't have stevia. So the garden of life has some greens, powders.
New Medica has greens, powders. There's a natural greens for biotics.
And what I suggest about those, I've personally, it's just a part of it's a matter of taste. We've
had people try different greens and they like them better than the greens first and that's great,
as long as they're a good balanced greens. The only issue that I have with some green powders that are
out there is that they aren't all just grown food. You mean, they're not just all whole food.
They are often they put in some synthetic nutrients, they might put in extra
methyl tetrahydrofolate, things like that because they think they're trying to make it just like
multiple. There is a grow greens by, I think it's neutral, neutral, neutral, ecology or something like
that, that we do have on the store that is organic greens and I don't think that one has stevia to
I've not tried that so you could try that one. That's probably the closest to the greens first
as far as its contents goes, but I've not tried it. Umedica makes some different greens shakes,
but I'm not so keen on those. They use whatever you see, natural flavorings. I'm always suspicious that
there's chemicals or that, monosodium glutamate or something like that to make them taste better and
yes, supplement companies do play those games on sometimes the cell product leg. Dr. Cutters,
I continue to appreciate all the support on receiving from your clinic. I have been with Saktin back
on our phone appointment regarding my latest labs which sell shall some of the two markers still
elevated and some remaining stable, but others were within dual range. My glucose continues to be higher
than optimal. This person's glucose still wasn't even over 100. Should I be changing anything I'm currently
doing? No, I think maybe getting another cheek swap every test something, is it might be a good idea?
On the other hand, I meant to ask about my current supplements I've heard on the Zoom calls and
it's a good to switch up supplements as well as diet is another cheek swap warranted. That's a good
question. How often should we do cheek swaps? A really great one line of thought is, hey, I've been doing
really great. I'm in a state of remission. I'm not really in the person just continues and they don't
change anything and they continue on their protocol. That's one philosophy and it can work really
well for some people. Other philosophies out there is that even when you're doing great, sometimes
it's good to change protocols. I tend to favor that and do another cheek swap because typically when
we test people, even if they're in a state of remission, they've been doing great for a year, we test
people. It changes. Your body changes. I take them off of things and change them onto something else
because that's what tests best for them. Cancer is always constantly changing and constantly trying
to find pathways a better replication and you just kind of got your better off state ahead of it.
So getting another cheek swap is more. How often should a person do a cheek swap? Well, certainly when
they have changes in their body, let's say their symptoms change majorly or something like that,
they don't feel well. If it's something like, hey, in the old days, I guess you'd go to the doctor
when I felt this way, that's the time they get a cheek swap. And then maybe every three to six months,
it's good just to get another cheek swap even if you're doing great. Thermography is a good to do
thermography. Well, you should follow the schedule of the thermography, the last thermography. So again,
you would not follow the schedule if you had changes, you felt another lump or something like that.
But when you do thermography, at least through a medical clinic, they'll say they'll give you, you
should do another thermography in six months or three months or nine months or 12 months and you
should just follow that schedule, unless there's changes. These things that I intended to bring up,
I'll be checking with labs to get a January, continue at regular detoxing right programs. The PA,
I have been seen for my thyroid medication is recommended that I do a cleanse.
Okay, so if you look at my detox course, you'll see that, you know, I don't really believe in doing
cleanses, you're constantly cleansing, you're constantly doing that, you're constantly supporting
detox pathways and such, you're doing coffee items, you are doing a cleanse. So I wouldn't think
that she thinks I have leaky gut. Well, certainly, we could do some tests for leaky gut. That would be
the Syrex 2, 3, X and Syrex 4 to test for those things. Those are good things to test for.
Can you just assume that everybody has leaky gut? Well, yes and no, but yes, it would be good idea
to be checking for that. If you could afford to do some lab, it's always better to do the labs.
So maybe, you know, you have a lot of questions, maybe we should just chat again and schedule a time
to chat with me again. What's the best time of day to do the cheek swab? When I said it,
will a blood, said it, I will get a blood test. So should I wait until you get the swab before I get
the blood test and make an appointment to speak with you? No, you could, there's not a best time
of the day to do the cheek swab. You shouldn't have food in your mouth just through the cheek swab.
We're just getting your DNA so it doesn't make any difference with time and then you're doing the
cheek swab. If you want to make an appointment with me that has to do with your information on your
blood test and we got to wait until we get your information of the blood results back. If all the
blood results are normal, then it really don't need to necessarily talk. Well, let's get your blood
test. Get the results, send those to me, then you can submit schedule of time to talk with them.
My AST and ALT, these are liver enzymes, are elevated, and the pharmacist has said it's like they do
to the gamma pentate. So what are things that could elevate your liver enzymes? Well, if I have
metastasis to my liver, my liver is going to be irritated, and that could elevate by liver enzymes.
Oftentimes, personally, if I'm a test to deliver, they don't even have elevated liver enzymes. So
if I had elevated liver enzymes, the first thing I would think of would would not be metastasis,
I think of what's affecting my liver currently. So even if you're like on ibiprofen,
that could raise your liver enzymes. It could be very irritating to your liver. Certainly
any prescription medication, if you're on chemotherapy, that can raise your liver enzymes. Anything
like that that could overwhelm your liver can raise your liver enzymes. So it's really nice that you have
honest pharmacists. And you can look up these, the drugs you're on, certainly do a Google search of
the different medications you're on and see the side effects of those drugs.
Problem is that the gamma pentate has taken away 75% of my hot flashes,
so my horrible blockers that I can finally sleep, how concerned are these level ast53,
ALT92? Well, again, it's like it's hard to say that, you know, it was just saying that there's
you know, I don't have to be worried about this. There's not going to be that much damage to my liver
at that. These are markers. So these are markers that your liver is being taxed. So
yeah, I mean, you got to balance it all out a little bit. Maybe just try to support your liver
in different ways. If you want to stay on the gamma pentate, because it's giving you a lot of
relief, then maybe just try to support your liver with doing more coffee. And I'm going to do it
more orchestral packs, things like that for your liver. Also, maybe talk to the pharmacist or the
prescribing doctor about reducing the dosage of the drug. Many people are surprised that if you
take 75% or maybe even 50% or even only 25% of the current drug, you're on or you, or you
titrate down to that, it still has the same effect. It still has the same benefit, but it's less toxic
to your body. So consider those options. You're on a lot of tumor or anything else, so we talked
about that. And you write programs, certainly the liver programs on the right. That's what I would
look at. The normalizing frequency folder has programs for different organs, and you can look at the
liver programs in the normalizing frequency. It's one of them. There's a different person asking this
question. In addition to the rash, I seem to be rotating fluid, arms legs face, coffee, could this
be related to kidney function or an allergic reaction or other? So when you're rotating fluids
and you're getting puffiness, you think of things like, okay, as they're blocked, lymphatic,
certainly if you're getting fluid in your face, your face is getting coffee and your arms and legs
that you don't think so much lymphatic. So you think lymphatic as if both your legs are swelling or
your one arm is swelling after surgery or something like that. There's a blocked lymphatic drainage.
When you have more systemic fluid, you think of things like allergy to something, and when you have
systemic inflammation like that, you think that I can reaction to a medication. That's what I would
think of. Certainly kidney function. So you're on the right track with that. Your kidneys are what
drain that. And certainly kidney function could affect that too. I would definitely get some blood work
to make sure your kidney function is within normal limits and that's cleared up. Okay, sorry,
it's finished. It says for my blood work yesterday, my eocidophils are high. So what we'll raise
eocidophils is different parasitic infections, fungal infections, most common thing that raises
eocidophils is allergic reaction. So parasitic infections, fungal infections, you don't think
that that ties to increase in retained retention and fluid. So that doesn't fit the piece there
in allergic reaction. Certainly ties into retained fluid and elevated eocidophils. So I'd
be concerned about possible reaction to a medication. So a person can have, so let's say a person's
not on any medication whatsoever, and they go in for a blood test and let's say they have really
bad allergy issues. Let's say like allergies to pollen or something like that, seasonal allergies,
and they get a standard CBC done at a physical, they can have elevated, just slightly elevated
eocidophils that has to do with that allergy, that their seasonal allergies. If a person doesn't
probe the seasonal allergies has never known to have elevated eocidophils at different times in the
year, there are undifferent medications and they have elevated eocidophils. Plus the retention of fluid,
I would definitely talk to the prescribing doctor about possible reaction to a medication.
As far as what relief you could do to that, always you want to find the reason why. So you want to do
what I just said and check it to talk to your prescribing doctor about that. As far as you got to figure
out the reason why first before you start trying to solve the problem. I use freezer pack mittens and
slippers for the first chemo and plan to use them again for the second as well. Second round is
tomorrow. However, I've been having occasional numbness and tingling in my fingertips. It goes
away for the most part. If I get active and intentionally pumped blood into my hands, is this
a sign of the beginning of neuropathy? It certainly can be neuropathy is going to be typically
neuropathy is going to start with tingling and some pain in your hands and tingling and then you're
going to get numbness. It goes to numbness. So anything can happen even after one round of chemo. So
the ice can help that. So using those freezer packs can be helpful.
If so, is this unavoidable at this point? Can I do something to stop it? I would say continue to do
those types of things. Again, you can look at the neuropathy posts and look at possibly using a
rebuilder. Make sure you're doing diali and pro wave. Make sure you're supporting liver, pathways,
everything that we talk about with liver and detoxeted and doing coffee animals and such like that
are going to be the best help to try to get that stuck out of your body so it's just the least
amount of damage to your peripheral nerves. The most recent scan results showed for colorectal cancer
going from stage 3, T3 to T4A to tumor penetration, penetrating the visceral peritone. I understand
there's a risk of perforation but not sure how significant. I talked to a radiation oncologist. He says
a low risk with certain current circumstances and oncologist makes it sound even more serious.
Seems to throw a wrench into some plants for metabolic treatment. So this person was considering
going a full metabolic approach going on a ketogenic type diet and funnel things back in the
direction of allopathic treatment, perhaps awkward to come in but welcome any thoughts anyway.
Yeah, I think it's hard to, it's always difficult to know what to do. Should I do chemotherapy and
radiation? Is it the right time to add that to my protocol? It's such a difficult thing to comment on.
But certainly if the cancer is not going in the direction that we want to be going at everything
that you're doing, you've got to consider other things. But doing a metabolic approach, this is
just what we talked about before. You're changing up your treatment. It's not like, I mean, I don't
think your oncologist is saying, you've got to do something right now, you've got to make a decision
in the next couple of weeks. We've got to move ahead with this. You still have time to try something
else. I mean, if it was me, I think I would switch up my treatment the way we've been talking about
and try this and see if that makes a difference within these three months and then you know,
set yourself some parameters. Okay, I'm going to try this and make this change for three months
and if there's, if I'm feeling better and you know, with the scans are not progressing in the wrong
direction, then I'm going to continue on with that. So I think you still have time to try some
different things. So that's what I would suggest. At the last oncology appointment, they were concerned
about possible infection. So they prescribed it antibiotic to take for five days. I protested because
I have a history of not tolerating antibiotics. But they said, five days would not be a problem.
Well, it was. And my God has been telling me, is there something I could do to improve that?
So when you take antibiotics, they, it damages your gut microbiota and antibiotics will damage
the cells, the gut lighting, the epithelial cells that might, the gut and it just throws off your
whole flora and throws off your everything. I'm not saying that you shouldn't take antibiotics
at different times, but some people are more susceptible to issues with antibiotics too. Personally,
I can take antibiotics and have no trouble. But honestly, I think I've taken antibiotics, you know,
maybe, maybe, you know, half a dozen times in my life. So it's, you know, and it's um, it partly
has to do with the healthy your gut before you start to take it antibiotics. What to do to improve
that though? You have to work on healing the gut. I would say start on some, so I think I made a
blog post, not specifically antibiotics, but let me go to that because I think I actually linked it
to our home page of the member site. So on the member site home page, I think I have a link to
uh, I don't know, I'll tell you that right now. Okay, so, oh, okay, so yes, I think it's the top
what ties into H-Pylorite because, you know, you think what is H-Pylorite? I have to do it,
let me take the antibiotics and damage in my gut because that's how H-Pylorite starts. So damage
gut, so H-Pylorite is killed by antibiotics, but it's not going to kill everything. So anything that
damages your gut increases the risk of H-Pylorite starting. So um, look at this post on it's called
H-Pyloricopactor pylori intramation and care. That goes through the different steps to do
to work on healing your gut. So it's the post that looks like that. So look at this post and it
goes through the steps stage one, look at dietary allergens. Well, that's not your issue. Make sure
you take your digestive enzymes with H-C-L in it because you need to support your stomach's
ability to break down the food. And many, many times that is the reason why people don't tolerate
antibiotics is because they have a decrease H-C-L in their stomach. So look at that part. Step two is
looking at supporting your gut. I would not take necessarily take para clear to begin with.
Let's see if I have more information on that. I will, if I, I will find the post
up on the member site that has more information on healing your gut and what to take for that. So
give me tell tomorrow when I'll do that. I went to an integrated clinic and they ran a metals test.
I tested high for copper. She suggested I stop taking the amymar because it has some copper
that you agree with this. I think we should do another cheek swab test. And can you send me the
tests that you had done, please? And then we should maybe have a conversation.
I heard my question about being coffee. It started two point two and a half weeks ago after my first
chemo. Yes, so certainly it could be a sensitivity to the chemo. It's just really the part of the issue
is that chemo is toxic. So you know, is it sensitivity? Is it an allergy or is it toxicity?
And it's affected my kidneys to make sure you get some kidney tests done and ask for that
even before your, your next chemo because they'll definitely do a white blood cell code, a CBC
make sure you look at some kidney function tests as well. Could you possibly suggest a good
allergy medicine for my cat allergies? Yes, it's called cat memoir. Just get rid of the cat.
I'm just kidding, just kidding. Okay, so cat allergies, you know, they're at the market. There's
over the culture anti-histamines of things that could help. And by the way, I have
part section by book about anti-histamines with cancer, particularly breast cancer.
They could be better official eating over the culture into histamines. But as far as nutrition to help
with any external exposure type allergens, whether it be environmental allergens from
animal dander or allergies from pollen and environmental things like that, you have to look at
clear histamines scavenger. We have three different main products for histamine issues because
that's what allergies do. They raise histamines. It would be the clear histamine scavenger is the
broadest that we have natural clear hist, which is some of just, I think it's four or five main things
that are common for airborne and environmental type allergies. And then we have histoclear,
which is DAO enzyme, which breaks down histamine in the gut. So that would be for mainly for food
based allergies. So don't get that one. So I would start with clear histamine scavenger. I think
that's the broadest. That's what I would start with. I think that's your best bet.
Is the rebuild or accessory for the right? No, it's something else completely. It's on our store.
It's a standalone little machine that looks like old skin's unit, but it's very, very different.
It's FDA-proof for neuropathy. Comes with all the instructions and such
and they're great little units. What are your thoughts about taking betanate clay internally for
detox help? So betanate clay is a great binder. So binds other things in your gut.
It's something that's in our clear binder product, our phase five clear binder.
And it's a great binder for things in your gut so that you don't reabsorb them.
Do you take it away from food at least and away from your other nutrients that you're taking?
So you're not binding anything that's bad. I'm glad you guys find my sense of humor.
It's not everybody does. So, um, yeah. So betanate clay is a great binder. So, um, let's see.
I don't know what I have. Okay, so if you just search gut on our blog, I have tons of blog posts
on gut health. Some of the things that you think of as far as healing your gut naturally,
you have to be careful when you have cancer because the most common nutritional product to
help heal your gut, going back to that question about the gut back here,
um, is, um, alglutamine because alglutamine helps epithelial cells reproduce so quickly. Well,
you don't want to necessarily do that when you have any form of cancer. But, like,
deglycerated licorice and um, a lot of the things that are even those healing products can be
beneficial. We have a product that we have private labels called clear GI. Now, it does have
some, um, uh, alglutamine in it. But it is the reason why a private label that product is because
out of all the gut products that has that are on the market, it has the least amount of
alglutamine. So, I thought that it was going to be fairly safe for our cancer patients.
Um, because I, you know, date of the, the product label tells you to take a table spoon
a day. And if you only take a teaspoon of it a day, you're only, you're getting 500 milligrams
of glutamine, which is far less than a lot of the gut healing products out there that, you know,
someone who have up to four grams of glutamine. So 500 milligrams or a half a gram of glutamine,
I thought was acceptable if you're taking it on a short-term basis to help heal the gut.
It also has all these other great things that are help that help with the gut, like slippery
elm and chamomile and okran, cat squad, MSL. And you're already taking, of course, a tonight thing.
But those are the things that can help heal the gut. But you want to add a probiotic also.
Um, and there's been tons of studies, medical studies out the last couple of years that show if you
take a probiotic, when do you take it antibiotic? If you have to take it antibiotic, definitely
reduces your issues that you can have. Next question, I've got some numbness around my underarm
because of my surgery. They said it takes time for the nerves to regenerate.
But some may be permanent. What else can I do to help that? That's where the rebuilder would come in.
That's one of the things that rebuilder does. It helps stimulate their growth at a much higher rate
using frequencies, the frequency of the nerve itself. But definitely helping detox,
doing everything you can to help detox the arms as well. The surgery caused physical damage,
done chemical damage like chemotherapy, but that can still help.
Sorry, did you say there are over-the-culture institutes, anti-histamines that are beneficial for
breast cancer. So yes, and over-the-culture, anti-histamine medication has been shown to help people
with breast cancer. And the real reason is because histamines can be a problem with all cancers,
but certainly have been shown through multiple studies to be a problem for those with breast
cancer. So anti-histamines taken just on a daily basis. Over-the-culture anti-histamine medication
have been shown to be helpful for those people with breast cancer. It can be helpful for any
cancer, but certainly with breast cancer. All right, any other questions? Or that high dose
melatonin is good for a scan with radiation.
Yeah, I've heard that before. I don't know that you can really
prove that, though. That's the difficult thing about something like that because you can't
really measure your rad dose of radiation, the damage to the tissues.
So, you know, it's like, oh, take high dose melatonin. It doesn't. There's some
sense to it from a metabolic pathway, but it's possible to really prove that.
Because you can't measure the damage, the post-damage radiation,
somebody who hasn't taken it, somebody who has taken it, but that is something that you can't
do. Certainly high dose melatonin can be beneficial for cancer in itself
and taking that before bed. We have some patients that are taking 100 milligrams of melatonin,
you know, before they go to bed. Thank you for considering that to me. I read some things about it,
but it's hard to measure that. What's the best heavy metal supplement?
I'm trying to think of a joke for that, but I'd better just plug my tongue.
So you're talking about detox in heavy metal, so you don't really want a heavy metal supplement.
But I'm sorry. I have very long sense of humor. But so I think as to detox heavy metals are, I would go to
the course, go to the seven phases of detox course. So if you've worked through all the phases of
detox and now you just want to keylate out the heavy metals, my favorite one is our phase zero
keylet clear. Also, the metal exitergy or the phase zero assist, our phase zero six can be very good.
Hey, but Hector Saul C is really good. That's another thing and then there's milder keylaters.
So part of it has to do if you have still have a lot of metal filling to your mouth, you can't use
a heavier key later. You can't use the one I first mentioned. If you don't have any heavy metals in
your mouth, if you don't have any implanted metals in your body, then you can use some of those heavier
things, but it's all listed on the seven phases of detox course.
You see any concern with doing high dose vitamin C in conjunction with radiation?
I do not. And you may want to talk to the place that you're getting high dose vitamin C,
but I have not heard of anything. And I think it can actually be helpful.
So some people say, well, don't take, but I'm not a fan of stopping any anti-oxidants when
you're doing radiation. So like when you do, if you're going to do chemo, I tell people to stop
taking anti-oxidants for 48 hours, I don't think you should do that with radiation. Radiation is
very pinpointed and very specific. And by taking anti-oxidants, you're not going to decrease the
effects of radiation. So it's you want to get that out of your body as fast as possible. It's
going to do its damage immediately. It's going to kill immediately. And you want to get that out of
your body right after. My tumors are in the left side of my neck, which have affected my left
parodid glands since January. It's extremely painful, stabbing pain. I can last several minutes
when I begin to eat or cry or many, many things trigger. And I dread it. Is there anything else
I can do to help it? I think you've tried some hot cold things on it that can decrease the pain
that can decrease the stabbing pain. I would think of that. And everything else that you're doing,
you're continuing to anything you can do to decrease the size of it and decrease the inflammation
is going to be your friend. So if you're doing the chemo pills on, I would say I would still do
the vitamin C IV. And the reason is that really high dose vitamin C, if you're doing vitamin C IV,
that's what you're talking about, high dose vitamin C. Many, many people think that it's really an
oxidative reaction, not an antioxidant. So I would continue it. There's a comment for Dina that
might be helpful. So when you go in there, don't you're not going to go in there and ask for specific
tests. You're just going to go and say, this is what my symptoms are. Can you test for kidney function?
You're not going to be able to go in there just ask for specific tests. So I would just tell them
what's going on. That you want to talk to the doctor. That this is what's happening. This is
five reaction. Let them examine you. Let them make the decision. They may decide to postpone it.
So you have to be ready for that, too. Okay, with that, I think we'll call it a night.
Thank you all for participating. We'll get this back up there. And we'll see you next week. Bye-bye.